the other day there was a girl that came
on my show and she was kind of wild to
know every time she's come on my show
she's kind of wilded out and I don't I
don't mind if girls are acting crazy on
my show I mean I make more money off of
it
like what do you mean obviously that's
entertaining she's very entertaining but
she was just saying some wild things on
a podcast so clearly you're gonna get
clipped
I don't know what you expect if you're
one of the most entertaining people on
the podcast we're probably going to take
clips of what you said and we always
link the full video so someone wants to
go back watch the full video they can
and this girl was particularly mad that
she was particularly mad that we said
that women date bad boys and then
complain because she proceeded to cry on
the podcast about dating a bad boy and
then you know she's complaining later
and I said to her that's what you did